we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P you can call the
voicemail number any time of day and
many people do here is a caller
suggesting you know David
maybe you're better looking off camera
maybe it's not really that bad take a
listen to this
so I
was over like television world
so when somebody is not like really
great on television
like in real life maybe you're like
better looking than you are on camera
I don't know why I find this so funny
not just a lot of people
and
you know I feel like there's something
against people who just aren't good on
camera yeah and it's like there's nobody
holding you accountable well listen I
you should look at my inbox there are
many people holding me accountable for
my physical appearance you should see uh
many of those uh people are peddling in
anti-semitic commentary about my
appearance which I will not indulge
anymore specifically right now but uh no
no no plenty of people are holding me
accountable for my physical appearance
rest assured if you were concerned we
have a great bonus show for you today we
talked at the top of the podcast about
Democrats saying Dianne Feinstein should
resign
we are going to talk on the bonus show
about Republicans lining up to say
Dianne Feinstein should not be replaced
on the Judiciary Committee this is a big
issue it's becoming a huge flash point
in Joe Biden's first term and judicial
nominations secondly we are going to
talk about the Supreme Court and the
potential restoration of religious
liberty in the workplace those sound
like dangerous buzzwords don't they yes
absolutely they are and George Anthony
De volder Santos has announced he's
running for re-election to serve the
people of the what is that the Third
District of New York I believe
um why is he doing it does he have a
shot what the hell is going on with this
guy we will talk about all of these
stories and more on today's bonus show
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves as bad we're gonna try
to make some money on the bonus show
join us by signing up at joinpakman.com
I will see you then